bonjour à tous Nous sommes en édition
spéciale ce matin est environ 5h20 quand
le journaliste animateur est influenceur
Samuel Etienne a publié un tweet
parfaitement incompréhensible mais qui
pèse comme une menace sur la paix du
monde regardez ce tweet s'il vous plaît
moi je suis en pleine forcling Point
Virgule
qfsq FZ
[Musique]
la mobilisation une première depuis la
Seconde Guerre mondiale ce discours
marque une nouvelle escalade du
président russe cette fois la cité Sion
la situation est un peu plus grave ou un
peu plus dramatique
un conflit général une guerre nucléaire
il ne faut désormais plus rien exclure
devant se discret bureau de recrutement
à Moscou les hommes et moins jeunes ont
conscience d'un tournant
monument le président dit que c'est
nécessaire vu la situation il n'y a pas
à discuter il le dit et c'est comme ça
si ils me disent de partir au front
Givet on mourra tout certains mourront
tout de suite d'autres plus tard il n'y
a pas avoir peur
aujourd'hui personne ne croit jamais au
pire l'histoire nous l'apprend personne
ne croit jamais au pire mais le pire
arrive puis si on nous échapper à ce
destin funeste même si ce mercredi la
tension entre l'Occident et la Russie
affranchi une étape ce à quoi nous
assistons depuis le 24 février dernier
est un retour à l'âge des impérialismes
et des Colonies ceux qui se taisent
aujourd'hui
servent malgré eux ou secrètement avec
une certaine complicité la cause d'un
nouvel impérialisme d'un cynisme
contemporain qui désagrège notre ordre
international sans lequel la paix n'est
possible et puis on constate un
phénomène incroyable des avions bondés à
destination des destinations pour
lesquelles les Russes n'ont pas besoin
de visa certains préfèrent quitter le
pays plutôt que d'être mobilisé il y a
deux il y a deux conclusions possible à
cette guerre qui dure maintenant depuis
plus de huit mois c'est que la Russie
gagne la guerre s'est épouvantable avec
la Russie perd la guerre c'était
épouvantable la seule façon pour moi la
seule façon pour moi actuellement de
s'en sortir pour tout le monde c'est que
cet homme disparaisse
c'est la seule façon et c'est la seule
issue pour nous parce que c'est lui le
symbole de cette guerre mais pour la
Russie aussi parce que si lui il
disparaît les gens autour de lui peuvent
dire c'est lui le responsable et nous et
on revient voilà à la situation
d'entente
espèce d'enfoiré chanter
ne le prenez pas mal ça a rien contre
vous
la répartie ça s'apprend des plus jeune
âge cette fille commence très bien dans
la vie pourquoi tu es trop moche
ta gueule avec une quinzaine de
volontaires on a signé pour un stage de
survie en Dordogne 48 heures en forêt
avec le strict nécessaire
[Musique]
l'intitulé du stage ça ne s'invente pas
[ __ ] et couteau la farine aux insectes
innovachides
une exceptionnelle levée de fonds 250
millions d'euros de quoi devenir le
géant mondial dans le secteur alors là
c'est pour les animaux mais la prochaine
étape c'est pour 2024 pour nous les
hommes c'est l'avenir c'est plein de
protéines vous goûtez à Pauline ou pas
alors j'ai goûté une fois sur un plateau
télé donc du coup j'étais obligée de
faire genre je trouvais ça bon c'était
un fait ah oui impressionnant tout est
pensé pour vivre en autarcie là c'est la
zone vraiment de survie production
d'énergie production d'électricité
production d'air ça c'est le vu des
locaux de stockage de nourriture et qui
fait avec ça
[Musique]
je vous présente
le trouver dans le jardin c'est notre
nouvel ami
c'est que l'eau de boisson ça d'accord
le fort est autonome en eau complètement
autonome en nous voilà donc même au cas
où il y aurait un problème de survie il
y a une petite chapelle et il y avait
une morgue d'accord avec six cercueils
partez mes enfants vous avez vous avez
vu
dans les cuisines des grands étoilés
vous reprenez notre idée parce que
franchement ça déchire c'est ça s'adapte
vu que la taille et l'élastique elle
s'adapte à toutes les têtes toutes les
formes de tête donc c'est à dire que ça
enveloppe bien que les chevilles tombent
pas tu as pas un cheveu qui s'évade ça
fait quoi là